huh families of two hostages one
American dr. Warren Weinstein and an
Italian Giovanni laporte oh who were
tragically killed in a US
counterterrorism operation Warren and
Giovanni were aid workers in Pakistan
devoted to improving the lives of the
Pakistani people after Warren was
abducted by al-qaeda in 2011 I directed
my national security team to do
everything possible to find him and to
bring him home safely to his family and
dedicated professionals across our
government worked tirelessly to do so we
also worked closely with our Italian
allies on behalf of Giovanni who was
kidnapped in 2012 since nine eleven our
counterterrorism efforts have prevented
terrorist attacks and saved innocent
lives both here in America and around
the world and that determination to
protect innocent life only makes the
loss of these two men especially painful
for all of us based on information and
intelligence we have obtained we believe
that a US counterterrorism operation
targeting and al Qaeda compound in the
afghanistan-pakistan border region
accidentally killed Warren and Giovanni
this past January yesterday I spoke with
Warren's wife Elaine and Prime Minister
Renzi of Italy as a husband and as a
father I cannot begin to imagine anguish
that the weinstein and lo Porto families
are enduring today I realized that there
are no words that can ever equal their
loss I know that there is nothing that I
can ever say or do to ease their
heartache and today I simply want to say
this as president and as
commander-in-chief and I take full
responsibility for all our
counterterrorism operations including
the one that inadvertently took the
lives of Warren
and giovanni i profoundly regret what
happened on behalf of the United States
government I offer our deepest apologies
to the families as soon as we determine
the cause of their deaths I directed
that the existence of this operation be
declassified and disclosed publicly I
did so because the Weinstein and the
Porto families deserve to know the truth
and I did so because even as certain
aspects of our national security efforts
have to remain secret in order to
succeed the United States is a democracy
committed to openness in good times and
in bad our initial assessment indicates
that this operation was fully consistent
with the guidelines under which we
conduct counterterrorism efforts in the
region which has been our focus for
years because it is the home of Al
Qaeda's leadership and based on the
intelligence that we had obtained at the
time including hundreds of hours of
surveillance we believed that this was
an al Qaeda compound that no civilians
were present and that capturing these
terrorists was not possible and we do
believe that the operation did take out
dangerous members of al Qaeda but we did
not know tragically is that al-qaeda was
hiding the presence of Warren and
Giovanni in this same compound it is a
cruel and bitter truth that in the fog
of war generally and our fight against
terrorists specifically mistakes
sometimes deadly mistakes can occur but
one of the things that sets America
apart from many other nations one of the
things that makes us exceptional is our
willingness to confront squarely our
imperfections and to learn from our
mistakes already I've directed a full
review of what happened we will identify
the lessons that can be learned from
this tragedy and any changes that should
be made we will do our utmost to ensure
it is not repeated and we will continue
to do everything we can to prevent the
loss of innocent life
not just innocent Americans but all
innocent lives in our counterterrorism
operations today we join their families
and friends and honoring Warren and
Giovanni to humanitarians who came from
different countries but who were united
by a spirit of service for decades
Warren lived the ideals of our country
serving with the Peace Corps and later
with the United States Agency for
International Development he devoted his
life to people across Africa and South
Asia he was a loving husband father and
grandfather who willingly left the
comforts of home to help the people of
Pakistan at the time of his abduction he
was a USAID contractor focusing on
helping Pakistani families escape
poverty and give a better life to their
children Giovanni's humanitarian also
took him around the world to the Central
African Republic to Haiti and ultimately
Pakistan like Warren he fell in love
with Pakistan and his people and
believed passionately lady could make a
difference in their lives Giovanni
service reflected the commitment of the
Italian people are great allies and
Friends to the security and dignity of
people around the world and today is a
reminder of the bonds of friendship
between our countries and the shared
values that bind Americans and Italians
together there could be no starker
contrast between these two selfless men
and they're all kinda captors Warren's
work benefited people across faiths
meanwhile al Qaeda boasted to the world
that had held warned citing his Jewish
faith al Qaeda held both men for years
even as Warren's health deteriorated
they deprived these men of precious
irreplaceable years but family who
missed them terribly amid grief that is
unimaginable I pray that these two
families will find some small measure of
solace in knowing that Warren and
Giovanni legacy will
door their service will be remembered by
the Pakistani men women and children
whose lives they touched and made better
their spirit will live on in the love of
their families who are in our thoughts
and prayers today especially Warren's
wife Elaine their daughters Alicia and
Jennifer and their families and the
shining example of these two men will
stand as a light to people the world
over who see suffering and answer with
compassion you see hatred and offer
their love who see war and work for
peace may God bless these two brave men
and may he watch over and comfort their
families for all the years to come